l'open de france de golf a fait recette
cette année plus de quarante huit mille
spectateurs se sont rendus au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pendant les quatre jours de compétition
l'une des principales raisons le plateau
de joueurs qui réunissait cette année
des têtes d'affiché de la discipline au
niveau du du plateau on n'a jamais été
aussi beau justin thomas américain fort
sympathique qui nous fait l'honneur
d'être là sergio garcia qui n'est jamais
venu ici
ce qui est important parce que c'est un
joueur culte 1 de l'équipe européenne
notamment le numéro deux mondiale justin
thomass a attiré toutes les attentions
conférence de presse la salle était
pleine à craquer pour capturer les
premiers clichés de l'américain de 25
ans à saint quentin en yvelines sur les
greens et spectateurs ont suivi avec
attention c'est parti
c'est un homme de grands grands talents
qui a une personnalité forte qu'à une
concentration exceptionnelle qui ne
s'énerve pas ou très peu qui qui est
fair play que c'est un monsieur c'est un
gentleman du golfe
je trouve que c'est bien parce que voilà
d'avoir des grands joueurs c'est quand
même mieux quand vous allez voir un
match de foot si oui à berne ots me
contre dortmund c'est d'aller voir et
chantilly contre contre asnières c'est
sûr non non je pense que c'est bien
d'avoir des grands joueurs ça ça
permettant de grandir encore une fois le
terrain de jeu était l'autre attraction
de ces quatre jours de compétition le
parcours refait à neuf pendant près de
dix mois pour la ryder cup a torturé des
joueurs est fasciné le public c'est un
golf extrêmement complexe et qui a fait
beaucoup beaucoup de progrès au fil des
années et je pense qu'aujourd'hui enfin
aujourd'hui et on va avoir un spectacle
étonnant
le rendez vous est donc pris pour la
ryder cup du 28 au 30 septembre prochain
cette fois-ci 60000 spectateurs
quotidiens sont attendus sur le site